flying free as a bird elegantly through
the air and over the landscape that's
the idea but somehow it looks different
with me the real question is whether the
illusion works
Oh
I am visiting the burglar center near
zurich in switzerland seven ella the
head of the center came up with the idea
for a bird flight simulator why are you
so fascinated by the fly of the birds
sister NATO's mia cowan doesn't he we
humans can't do it birds can move in
extremely complex ways they can land on
a dime which no airplane can manage they
can lift off very fast and they can
maneuver among the branches and we as
humans have no chance of doing anything
like what a bird can do an DKT vehicle
tomorrow gulls are breeding here at the
moment from little hats you can watch
the birds without disturbing them the
birth center tracks twelve thousand
visitors a year and stefan hella wanted
to offer them more than just observation
huts and an exhibition he wanted a
flight simulator but one that simulates
bird flight not an airplane max Reiner
made the simulation possible he and two
colleagues at the zurich University of
the Arts developed what they call
thirdly this platform gives you the
feeling that you're really in the air
and navigating yes yeah
max's team worked for half a year
developing birtley he shows me where you
have to press here and everybody now the
biggest challenge for the team was
getting the mechanics to mesh smoothly
with a computer software matthew leak is
the overall experience is more intense
when every aspect works together when
all your senses play along and tell you
that you're really aloft and flying
that's very different from watching it
on TV now you can put your hands in here
this is like your wings now I'll give
you a pair of 3d glasses with the
glasses you're really thrust into the
landscape now you also get headphones so
that you really hear everything
happening around you that's our vehicle
ish Alice was in d dot okie I'm flying
over San Francisco we are used to seeing
cities from above almost everyone has
stood on top of a high rise and looked
down so we have a better feel for
dimensions among buildings than a nature
that makes the virtual experience more
realistic and that's why the team chose
an urban backdrop for the bird flight
simulator I flap my wings and up I go I
get used to maneuvering with my wings
quickly after a short time I forget all
about the real world a fan simulates the
width the interplay between the virtual
world in my goggles and the real motion
of the machine produces a realistic
illusion
Twista beastin row now you have to rise
up a bit go up go up go up no that was
too close you've crashed this deck is
Angus students it just really feels like
flying and yeah you really if you see a
building you just wanna avoid yes a
violent end and then just a keep keep
flying and you get a pict if you really
want to do it once more and more the
bird flight simulator is indeed
addictive during my second flight I felt
a little sick but the simulator is so
much fun I'm willing to accept that ok
so now try taking a look at your hands
see still he's leaving my wings plus
this what makes me happy is that people
are content when they've finished when
they get out of the machine they're all
very happy I think that's remarkable
simply flying makes you happy sam zeff
llegan simply flying well we humans will
never be able to fly in the air as
smoothly as birds but a flight with
Berkeley comes pretty close
you